you you talked about
the essentially the people who hit in
protest just to take an instagram photo
right like that's something i feel like
you might have talked about on another
record
i feel like there was a record where you
kind of had a conscious take last year
that we had talked about i don't know if
was it a jim jones record was it was it
but no i'm trying to think i did i did a
lot i did a lot last year
but yeah it's crazy because we we in
2021 now you know i think last year you
know the country went through a lot you
know what i'm saying
but i didn't i do notice nowadays like
it's a lot of fake woke ass
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
yeah it's like that woke [ __ ] turns into
a trend is it it's
it's just trendy yeah
and then it's kind of spinning to like
just the cancel culture [ __ ] that's
going on
yeah it's like man it's like people are
really out here
like looking for opportunities just to
look good on instagram
and or just to [ __ ] on somebody's life
it felt like that's
that's what it feels like and that's
where that that
you know that line came from that bar
came from you know i mean it do feel
like that
you know but you know i just
mind my business man i stay out of the
politics and all that [ __ ]
you know i mean i i use my voice through
action
you know what i'm saying i i've received
like you know proclamations in the city
yeah erie county legislative you know i
mean and
the mayor and all type of you know you
don't got to advertise what you yeah
and a lot of you by example i don't even
post all the things that i've
done right right right right you know
what i'm saying because that ain't what
i do it for like
i always hated them type of [ __ ] that
[ __ ] see a [ __ ] homeless and
[ __ ] in front of them
i mean they [ __ ] videotape them
giving them money or something yeah
it's like what are you doing while
they're handing them a dollar and [ __ ]
like i always hated [ __ ] like that
and you know i don't care nobody like i
said like
i really don't care nobody think of what
i do
and all that [ __ ] i just always want to
be remembered for my character
and just being a real [ __ ] being solid
man and just always
again i gave my people the shirt off my
back man i just
i just got a big heart i don't know how
to tell people no sometimes
so you know i don't even remember
where the question was no no no i mean
you pretty much nailed it
you know what i'm saying